Democrats are upset about speeches like
that and about the Trump presidency
itself of course but for more than a
year they've consoled themselves by
looking ahead to the midterms the 2018
congressional elections and they thought
to themselves we're gonna win big we're
gonna take back power and they may but
recent polls show that Democrats once
massive lead is shrinking and now to
almost nothing
a new poll over at CNN shows the
Democrats have only a three point
advantage on a generic Congressional
ballot is this real what does it mean
what is going on here Tom Bevin
co-founder of Real Clear Politics
follows the stuff carefully for a living
and he joins us tonight now what is this
about Tom and is it real oh I definitely
think it's real Tucker you go back and
look in mid-december the Democratic lead
in the generic ballot and that's the
question if the election were held today
would you vote for the Republican or
Democrat Democrats had a 13-point lead
as of today it's down to 6 in our
RealClearPolitics average and as you
mentioned the CNN poll went from 16
point lead for Democrats two months ago
down to three we've got another poll
showing it down to one point so this is
real and it is just as a point of
reference in 2006 when Democrats won 30
seats they finished with a seven point
nine percentage lead in the generic
ballot and so they're at six now and
they need about twenty four seats so I
think they're in that that range where
it's making them very very nervous so
Republicans in Congress have been
assuming for months I've talked to them
that they're gonna lose big and that
Nancy Pelosi or whomever is going to be
the speaker now they think they've got a
shot but they're concerned about
intensity voter intensity on the left is
really really strong is that how
meaningful is that intensity oh it's
meaningful particularly in a midterm
election where it's all about turning
out the base and Democrats have had
advantage in that but again back to that
CNN poll that was another finding that I
think was disturbing for Democrats they
showed that Republic intensity is up now
and was matching the level of Democrats
and and if that's the case it's not at
all sure bet the Democrats would take
back the house in November there's a
little confusing and Trump's personal
approval numbers are confusing given
that the stormy Daniels story which is
the single most important story ever
covered by the
good news media and we both agree on
that has dominated the coverage for the
past three or four weeks month two
months I don't know how long it's been
that hasn't had an effect no in fact
it's just the opposite
Tucker back in mid December was Trump's
low point in the Real Clear Politics job
approval rating his average was 37 he's
now at forty four point three so he's
gained or forty three point four he's
he's gained six six and a half points
over the course of that period and as
you mentioned the entire time it's been
in the stormy Daniels onslaught it has
not only has it hurt his numbers his
numbers have been ticking upward the
entire time and again that's something
that then you see Democrats how you talk
to them they're there now somewhat
annoyed by this because you talked to
Nancy Pelosi and others they say look
this is distracting from our message
they want to try and get back to to
reaching voters and voters have actually
tuned that out now and are paying
attention to the other stuff which Trump
has had a pretty good few weeks amazing
their message we don't have time for you
to tell me what that is but I appreciate
it Tom thank you you bet
was you just heard the numbers on the
upcoming midterm election aren't
interesting the Democrats are still
ahead but they're not nearly as popular
as they were six months ago and that is
weird the president still disliked by
half the country
congressional Republicans in the polling
or even less admired than he is so
Democrats ought to be way ahead and as
you just heard they're not so why is
that could it be that for all the
problems with the Republican Party and
those problems are real Democrats are
perceived as even less appealing looks
that way the question is why we have
some theories we could show you a
million examples to illustrate this but
here's one from just yesterday that came
immediately to mind watch is this MSNBC
panel which is as close to a Democratic
Party focus group as you'll ever find
gushes over that poorn lawyer the one
whose eyes are too close together you
know the one who's always on television
making threats watch this
Michael avenatti is a beast okay that's
true and he's a beast
he's a beast and he keeps popping Donald
Trump in all of his folks in the mouth
Jon Meacham says he may be the savior of
the Republic it's really interesting
killed the news of the Iran deal
practically in one big stroke he really
is a master of the media cycle I Oh
Michel avenatti an apology for the last
couple of weeks I've been saying enough
for reading Michel I've seen you
everywhere what do you have left to say
I was wrong brother you have a lot to
say the Democrats could learn something
for you you are messing with Trump a lot
more than they are so here's a protocol
rule of thumb if the creepy porn lawyer
is quote the savior of the Republic in
your view you're probably not trying
very hard to appeal to middle America
and Democrats are not in fact in the
last year and half the Democratic Party
has doubled down on every behavior they
got Trump elected in the first place
they routinely vilify tens of millions
of Americans based on how they look they
prefer illegal immigrants to US citizens
at this point they don't even hide that
preference they're open about it
in schools and sports in the military
they denounced the idea of biological
differences between men and women that's
something that every culture from
ancient Egypt till about 20 minutes ago
understood perfectly well because it's
demonstrable they don't recognize it
anymore
then two nights ago the New York Times
criticized the Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo and his trip to North Korea they
ran the headline at a key moment
Trump's top diplomat is again thousands
of miles away like it was a sin but the
purpose of his visit you'll recall was
to secure the release of three American
prisoners but the time she's not
impressed by that
Pompeyo works for Trump so the whole
thing must be bad whatever else he's
done Trump has driven the Democratic
Party off the deep and then I only hate
him but the country that elected him and
it's starting to show in the polls
Christie Setzer's president new heights
communications she's been in and around
the Democratic Party for a long time and
she joins us tonight
so I mean you heard Tom Bevan say you
know they're mad that their message
isn't getting out but the truth is their
messages Trump is bad and that's not
really a message right that's more an
animal reaction whatever their message
is it's actually working if you look at
the congressional and state level
elections that have happened since
November 2016 Democrats have flip 40
plus seats at the state legislative
level and often in districts where Trump
actually won by twenty or thirty points
so we can quibble about what the message
is and but we can't really quibble right
now about whether or not it's working
because it clearly seems to be well it
mean
of course to some extent I mean Trump is
still like loathed by half the
population it's his first midterm so
historically of course they're gonna
pick up seats the question is where's
the wave and if you listen what the
message really is one of the messages is
for example that there are no
differences between the sexes that
biological reality is like fake by
nobody saying I mean we need to
reorganize Society along those lines
that's way more radical anything from
has ever said I would suggest that you
point me to the candidate that is saying
that in making that their real message
no look Democrats are being reasonable
election there it is would it be
possible for a Democrat running for
office in a Democratic primary to say
there are two biological sexes male and
female and that's it that's what our
biology tell you said I would suggest
they talk about the economy know what I
mean they're trying to Ryoga
they're pushing all these changes on the
rest of us including the bathroom thing
all this you couldn't say it's
Republicans who are doing the bathroom
thing I again North Carolina that was a
that was a entirely no one even imagined
there were more than two sexes until
about twenty minutes ago it was Democrat
so but I'm just saying that's a big
change maybe there may be biology isn't
real but that's not a mainstream
position and they spent a lot of time
talking about it does that help I would
say that if you wanted to make the
argument to me that Democrats should or
should not be talking about impeachment
they should or should not be spending
lot of time on stormy Daniels and
Michael avenatti
we can have that conversation and I
would be happy to but there is no
mainstream Democratic candidate who is
talking about as you said you know you
can say as a Democrat I'm serious cuz I
think that's reordering society's always
a big deal mhm and pretending biologies
fake is to so you could have a
democratic candidate would say there are
two biological sexes that's it he could
get away with that
i I don't think that they have been is
what I'm saying and I think again if you
look back to the ways that Democrats
have been performing up to this point
whatever it is that they're doing is
working there is far more energy there
is more small dollar donations and that
leads into more volunteers and it leads
to a better slate of candidates in the
Democratic lot it is true I think you're
absolutely right there's probably more
energy more money and all that I just
I'm waiting for the wave we'll see I
hope you'll come back election night
thank you mister thank you